okay Oh adults hanging out like a stupid
boss have you ever done Z sterling
Lindsay if you don't know her you are an
idiot she gives much joy to the world in
forms of dance violin just overall very
entertaining wonderful videos and live
performances we are very close to
Valentine's Day and I thought it would
be really fun for Lindsay and I to give
you guys the best advice that we can
possibly give you as to adults about
dating and relationships to help prepare
you for this inevitable day that is both
wonderful and completely terrible what I
think this is good because I think we
have multiple perspectives here yeah
we've both been at one point another
either dating someone or single
Valentine's Day so yes
whatever side you may find yourself on
we maybe have the answers what is your
guttural reaction when you hear the term
Valentine's Day are you like oh sweet or
you're like I hate that day I am ashamed
to say I'm one of the I hate that day
people I just hate that it's like put on
this pedestal I think it puts undue
pressure on people so it's one of the
most like strictly commercial holidays
I'll bet were there or it's like the
industry is really just trying to milk
you for your money to prove that you're
in love there I went on Twitter and
asked you guys for your questions using
the hashtag asked lace because I shipped
us already at our ship name is lace how
appropriate how do you go in for the
first kiss what see is this a guy or a
girl I think it's just onion rings oh
that's always a tough situation I feel
like it's very individualized to
whatever your situation happens to be I
mean if you're really asking for it
there's the good old fashioned you just
hold that look I mean if you're standing
really close to someone and you just
hold that yeah that takes a little bit
of guts though especially if you're not
quite at that spot where you know you're
gonna be both
and going for the kiss you have to
assume that there might be consequences
it's like when you eat Taco Bell
like I think just making sure that
they're aware that you want that
affection whether it's say I'm gonna
demonstrate on grace oh my god just
being extra touch you extra touchy so
like when it's not necessarily just you
know putting your arm on them and your
hand on their legs do you like this
alright they might have that reaction
and that's a no-go that means that
probably this isn't what they were
hoping for free of the signals read
those signals and if they are feeling
kind of the same way they will kind of
reciprocate like that yeah then you're
like okay but I'm definitely game on
from this channel what can you get
yourself for Valentine's Day that's the
best idea ever
yeah I would say treat yourself treat
yourself to something that you actually
enjoy if that's staying in and watching
television or a movie and just eating
some cool food great job if it's trying
to go out meet other people cool job
give yourself the gift of your own
comfort zone I like that a lot I like
this guy but how do I find out if he
likes me back this is tough a lot of
times we ladies assume that guys read
our signals a lot yeah better than they
do so there have been times when I'm
like I've totally been very obvious yeah
he's not reciprocating obviously he's
not interested but then you find out in
hindsight that they had like no idea
you're like I was so obvious all of the
eye blinking was that I love you and
make sure that if you're flirting you're
flirting in a way that is much it that's
not just a friend type of flirting yeah
be a little obvious also I wouldn't say
no to the idea of you getting a friend
to kind of swoop in and feel the person
out for you like that how to tell
someone you
like them this is easier said than done
clearly but you only live once so just
tell that person that you like them if
it's a friend and you're worried about
ruining the friendship and that requires
a little more thought just be bold you
can feel that chemistry chances are they
probably can too if they're not reading
into the emojis that you're sending move
on to sending just straight-up dick pics
and see what happens really well you
know teach the wrong how to deal with
not having a Valentine I have plenty of
experience in this category I remember
one year I was like I don't want to be
sad I'm Dan Allen tines day and I have
this pressure so I actually threw like a
girl party oh and it was really fun
everyone had to wear pink or red and
then we decorated and it wasn't like a
we hate men day or anything that it was
more just like having fun all the
decorations were pink and the deserts
were pink and it was just fun I think
it's really easy to feel sorry for
yourself on Valentine's Day and it's a
little harder but I think much more fun
to try and just say like screw
everything I'm gonna have a dumb silly
fun time and also thinking of it is it's
a day about love it's not necessarily
about romanticism what not to do on a
first date I think one of the things
that you shouldn't do on a first date is
not let yourself have a good time if the
person doesn't like you as yourself and
it's just a waste of money at a macaroni
grill at that point and an hour of your
life that you'll never get back you know
there's that fine line of like sharing
too much and not sharing enough and we
all I think know where we air making
sure that you're not like too closed off
because you can't get to know someone if
you're not willing till I put yourself
out there a little bit and get a little
bit personal yeah but without sharing
the skeletons in the closet make sure
like okay tonight I'm gonna open up more
or tonight I'm not gonna talk about you
know about funny mole on my behind I've
heard so many stories of Lindsay's mole
bag
also maybe pack some sort of like
stomach medicine because sharding on a
first date is not the best thing to do
experience no I just watch youtube
videos what is love baby don't hurt me
don't hurt me I don't have the licensing
for that okay
there are so many different kinds of
love some people have very fun loving
relationships some are like spicy and
romantic and sizzly all the time you
just have to define what you want out of
love love is basically like a cheesecake
factory man yeah it's just fast analogy
I've ever heard
there's so many pages of different kinds
and it's up to you to choose the one
that's best for you well there you go
there's all our advice for you guys for
this up and coming a Valentine's Day
hopefully it's helpful Lindsey where is
the best place for all of these lovely
human beings to find you on the Internet
oh my goodness you can come visit me on
my youtube channel
Lindsey stomp or just look me up Lindsey
Stirling and your tour is announced
right yes I'm touring all over the world
will be in Australia Asia and and South
America soon and then of course US will
be coming and Europe Lindsey Stirling
calm and click on the tour section
thanks so much for being here Lindsey
thanks for having me grace this is so
fun I don't know
and also don't count yourself out there
have been so many times when I've been
like oh he wouldn't he's not my type
he'd never like me that's not you know
never never assume that because you'd be
surprised ladies and gentlemen yeah
everybody's got a chance even two girls
in a couple of cat onesies I